some details
with the russian federation and i hope
that we will have
a real
practical in practice
a settlement process
a peace uh
process to end the war but
a hundred percent
so there should be a ceasefire
if there are hundreds of thousands of
people or ten
tens of thousands of people
whom russia is now mobilizing and if
they come here with uh hundreds and
thousands of tanks they will and to keep
we understand that if they
do carpets or bombings and uh
and if they decide to erase the
historical memory of this whole
region
the
history of the kievan rusty history of
europe yes they will end the key of them
if they destroy all of us
they will answer kiev
yes they should demonstrate uh how
influential they are i rang them and i
said please ring the person who is in
moscow who doesn't talk to me
otherwise i would talk to that person
myself
so i rang them and thank god we have
good relations with emmanuel
and with uh the german chancellor he
responded so and anjay
responded
so i discussed this with
the german and the french leaders that
they have to talk to putin today
that the mayor should be released